für den feuerwehrmann ist nach die
schussfahrt zum einsatz
bei unserem szenario des asyl camps gibt
es natürlich keine solche rutsche oft
überhaupt keinen ausgang oder ausweg
genau dieses szenario nimmt die berliner
theatergruppe martina ex auf sie macht
den zuschauer zum flüchtling mit ihrem
stück stoff passt kassiert die nächste
woche in der gessnerallee zürich
wir haben das stück in köln gesehen darf
jetzt durch die grenze sie bleibt zu ein
auffanglager als niemandsland
hier werden die zuschauer zu beteiligten
ihr ziel die einreise in die sichere
lyrische republik überhaupt niemand
pläne aber wir wollen euch trotzdem
nicht doch um über die grenze zu kommen
müssen sie erst verschiedenste probleme
lösen
wie fühlt es sich an keiner passt zu
haben auf der flucht zu sein
auch thilo ausbauen lässt sich für einen
abend auf dieses emotionale experiment
ein
und schnell steckt das team während
bürokratie labyrinth muss sich
anscheinend fälschen weil meine
botschaft wenig hilft die bürgschaft da
bei euch freunde in der loge republik
die finde ich anscheinend im internet
aber ich habe kein geld mehr um ins
internet zu gehen
gleichzeitig verselbstständigt sich das
leben im lager amtliche willkür herrscht
krankheiten blüten korruption macht sich
breit
ein verbrechen sorgt nachts wird illegal
besorgt situationen die den meisten
teilnehmern wohl fremd sind
das gehört zum konzept von martin riggs
das theaterkollektiv kreiert
ausschließlich mitmachtheater
prinzipiell finde es interessant
situationen wo vielleicht gleichzeitig
spaß mache aber auch potenziell zum
nachdenken anregen so ganz passen
menschlichen grundzug zum vorschein
es gibt extrem sozial spielen extrem
egozentrisch und egoistisch spielen und
das ist interessant sie setzen sich
wie geldverdienen im lager stumpfsinn
und schikane ziehen sich durch das stück
die grenze aber bleibt unüberwindbar und
im beruf nach was kriege ich glaube ich
mache aus der fabrik aber dass die
fabrik betreiberin leider schon getürmt
und einen solchen alarm bringt
zusätzlichen stress und chaos in den
bürokratischen spießrutenlauf marina ex
lässt keine katastrophe aus
alle szenario spielt also mit das
flüchtlingsboot oder so sondern das gute
bewertung dass viel mehr bürokratische
aspekte zu verlagern
in einer reihe auf dem platz versammeln
und aufzug heraus
nach drei stunden beklemmende
mitmachtheater droht die räumung des
lagers
das ist die spielen also ein bisschen
kopfschmerzen schon aber
wenn man das wirklich durchhält ist das
erzeugt auch dieses dieses gefühl von
man könnte gar nicht alles schaffen was
man schaffen möchte
das stück endet im leeren der
heranfahrenden bulldozer an die das
lager und die hoffnung unter sich
begraben fast alle flüchtlinge bleiben
zurück auch thilo hat es nicht geschafft
also alles was wir heute erlebt haben
war war willkür ist hätte zu jedem
zeitpunkt genau andersrum sein können
und dem ist man einfach ausgesetzt wenn
man wenn man hier ein bewohner ist